l'open de france le plus gros
rendez-vous golfique de l'hexagone a
débuté ce jeudi à saint quentin en
yvelines pour cette 100e édition les
organisateurs s'attendent à accueillir
plus de 60000 spectateurs sur les quatre
jours de compétition
les supporters ont déjà pris place à
côté des greens c'est un tournoi qui
attire beaucoup de monde donc un
passionnant avec des gros joueurs donc
c'est passionnant d'être ici je pense
que c'est un tournoi qui monte en
puissance surtout avec le la ryder cup
dans deux ans je crois que il y en aura
de plus en plus de grands joueurs sur
l'open de france
la vingtaine de loges de l'open de
france est également garni comme tous
les ans d'une capacité de 50 à 250
personnes les espaces équipés de balcons
accueil des professionnels et des
célébrités ont si on a la chance d'aller
voir arriver on a la chance de stresser
avec eux parce qu'il ya quand même pas
mal de dos auto il ya du vent et
il ya quelques gouttes de pluie mais ça
va pas durer donc dans ces moments en
fait on est content de se retrouver ici
sur le plan sportif le public peut voir
en action huit vainqueurs de majeurs 87
vainqueur sur le tour et 18 jours de
ryder cup
la super star de cette édition 2016 et
le nord irlandais rory mcilroy numéro 3
mondial au niveau de vente de
billetterie
c'est important c'est énorme + 40 %
comme comme et la moyenne et on le
ressent complètement ayant le sens
aujourd'hui parce qu'il ya énormément de
monde on n'a jamais vu autant demande un
jeudi le premier jour à 8 heures ce
matin ces foules
le golf national fort à ses comptes ce
dimanche 3 juillet au soir la coupe sera
remise aux alentours de 17h30 au
vainqueur